[Musik]
willkommen hier bei Bild ja welche
Konsequenz hat die Politik aus der
brutalen Gewalt in der Silvesternacht
gezogen mittlerweile bisher muss man
leider sagen keine es gab Empörung es
gab Betroffenheit und viel rumgedruckte
vor allem wenn es um diese Frage ging
was hat diese Straßengewalt eigentlich
auch mit Migration zu tun darüber
diskutieren wir jetzt ganz offen ganz
ehrlich in dieser Runde hier mit Torsten
frei nämlich
unionsfraktionsfriese hier bei Bild
seeliferei ebenfalls im Studio linken
Politikerin aus Berlin bei uns der
Sprecher der Polizei Gewerkschaft in
Berlin Benjamin Centro und Wolfgang
Malik ein grüner aber vor allen Dingen
ein Sozialarbeiter an der Basis im
Offenbacher Nordend da ist der Chef
eines Boxclubs in allen herzlich
willkommen hierher jentro mit ihm möchte
gerne anfangen und noch einmal kurz
zurück anklicken auf die Geschehnisse in
der Silvesternacht aber vor allen Dingen
auf das was wir mittlerweile wissen
haben Sie genügend Fakten um zu sagen ja
da gibt es möglicherweise einen
bestimmten Typus der an dem Abend in der
Nacht gewalttätig war ich glaube es gibt
viele Leute die das momentan behaupten
Typus ist erstmal der dass wir Menschen
haben die andere Menschen angreifen ja
ganz bewusst mit Gegenständen mit
Schreckschusspistolen vor allem eben
auch mit Pyrotechnik aber alle die auch
in den ersten Tagen darüber gesprochen
haben wir wissen ganz genau wer es ist
es sind alles junge Männer mit
Migrationshintergrund wir sollten mal
ganz ehrlich sein zu vielen dieser Taten
in der Silvesternacht haben wir noch
nicht mal Tatverdächtige ja wir haben
alle Bilder gesehen gerade auch in
Social Media weil Leute sich selbst
gefilmt haben das dann reingestellt
haben aber ich glaube die Berliner
Polizei geht ja sehr transparent mit um
dass man noch gar nicht zu allem
überhaupt nicht die hat geschweige denn
auch wirklich die Taten jemand zuordnen
kann es ist schwer zu ertragen ja frei
mich wundert das gerade dass er irgendwo
da der auch wirklich ein Ohr ganz nicht
an der Polizei hat dass er sagt ja jetzt
mal Moment das muss alles ganz in Ruhe
erstmal ermittelt werden die Videos sind
bei weitem noch nicht ausgewertet es
wird noch eine lange Zeit brauchen dass
wir jetzt nach gut drei Wochen nach
dieser Silvesternacht so wenig Fakten so
wenig Informationen haben also wir haben
Fakten in bestimmten Bereichen und den
anderen mag es noch im Bereich der
Spekulation sein aber wir wissen
natürlich vieles es ist ja nicht so
entscheidend ob das jetzt nur Angriffe
auf Sicherheitskräfte mit Pyrotechnik
war sondern tatsächlich sind jedenfalls
eine ganze Reihe von Straftaten passiert
auch wenn es brandstiftung ist auch wenn
es Behinderung von Rettungskräfte ist
auch wenn es körperverletzung ist oder
vieles andere mehr wir haben jedenfalls
mit Ausschreitungen in der
Silvesternacht zu tun gehabt in Berlin
aber auch anderen Ort wie es ein
Rechtsstaat nicht dulden darf und
deswegen muss man sagen
selbstverständlich muss man das exakt
auswerten muss schauen was ist durch wen
tatsächlich passiert aber das wird er
ein ganz großes Problem haben über das
wir jedenfalls sprechen müssen das
scheint mir offensichtlich zu sein und
deswegen
muss man auch damit leben dass wir genau
diese Fragen thematisieren und die
müssen ohne Schaum vor dem Mund aber
offen und ehrlich passieren wir müssen
eine ganze Reihe von Fragen gestellt
werden also zunächst einmal haben wir
die Situation dass man in Berlin
schlechter mit dieser Herausforderung
zurechtkommt als anderen Orts das hat
auch etwas mit den gesetzlichen
Rahmenbedingungen von von Gewalt von
Jugendgewalt von junger geworden von
Jugendgewalt natürlich kann man auch die
Frage stellen wo gelingt Integration
besser als anderen Orts auch darüber
muss man sprechen es sind eine ganze
Reihe von Fragen und die es geht und das
erste ist dass man offen und transparent
damit umgeht ohne Scheuklappen und sagt
was nicht sein kann das darf eben auch
nicht in den ersten Tagen frei in den
ersten Tagen hat die Polizei in Berlin
das ja gemacht hat relativ schnell dann
doch nach 48 Stunden auf dem Tisch
gelegt welche Nationalität die
Tatverdächtigen hatten da waren
überproportional viele Ausländer erstmal
dabei afghanische Pass würden sagen das
war am Ende ein Querschnitt der
Bevölkerung der dort so ja diese
Straftaten begangen hat in der
Silvesternacht also es ist so dass ja
die Zahl nach aktualisiert wurden 44
Menschen wurden festgenommen und davon
waren ungefähr 40 Prozent Menschen mit
einem nicht deutschen Pass und wenn ich
mir die Bevölkerung angucke und ich
arbeite und lebe in Neukölln und
Kreuzberg und kenne mich da ganz gut aus
in der sonderallee ich habe mir die
Strukturdaten auch noch mal angeguckt
befindet sich genau diese Bevölkerung
vor Ort also in den Zahlen der
Beschuldigten finden sich die
Betroffenen wieder was die
Innenverwaltung festgestellt hat dass
vor allem in Berlin in sozial
benachteiligten Quartieren ist zu
Ausschreitung gekommen ist deswegen
sagen wir auch wir müssen uns das
Phänomen Jugendgewalt in Gänze anschauen
das ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches
Problem und das kann man nicht
reduzieren auf Fragen von Integration
oder Migration sondern es geht um
Jugendgewalt und die gehen wir mit
jungen Gewalt um wie verhindern wir das
so etwas wieder passiert weil da müssen
wir alle daran einen Interesse haben und
nicht jetzt vor allem populistisch
schnell nach irgendwelchen schnelleren
schärferen Gesetzen und höheren Strafen
schreien vor allem wissen wir durch
kriminologische Studien das habe ich
zumindest in meinem Studien gelernt dass
höhere Strafen gar nicht abschreckend
wirken und gar nicht den Effekt haben
den sich vielleicht wieder diskutieren
wir gleich wir sind noch ein Stück in
Schritt davor noch einmal zu gucken wer
sind die Tätergruppen sie sagen jetzt im
Grunde interessiert sie der Pass gar
nicht
ich sage dass der Pass hier kein
konkreten Zusammenhang zu den Taten
gehabt hat also weil es ist noch nicht
aus ermittelt sagt der frei Herr jentro
mitten auf dem Weg die Berliner Polizei
sagt das wird noch Monate dauern bis wir
da Ergebnisse haben naja wir können
natürlich jetzt noch nicht im Einzelnen
feststellen was ist die Motivation genau
der Menschen gewesen ich kann nur sagen
bei denjenigen die festgenommen wurden
das Spielen sich die Bevölkerungszahlen
vor Ort eins zu eins wieder weil ich mir
das angeguckt habe wie viele Menschen
hatten einen deutschen Pass wie viele
Menschen haben einen
Migrationshintergrund von den Deutschen
und da kann ich nur sagen das ist ein
Spiegelbild der Menschen die in der
Heide sieht Siedlung oder in der
Sonnenallee leben welche Motivation
passiert bitte warum ist es dann gerade
dort in Neukölln passiert die Frage muss
man ja auch beantworten natürlich muss
man die beantworten ich habe ja schon
ein teilansatz geliefert weil die
Innenverwaltung der festgestellt hat
dass es vor allem in sozial
benachteiligten passiert das allerdings
muss man auch sagen in Sachsen gab es
nicht im selben ausmacht aber auch
Ausschreitungen
gegen Polizeibeamte wurden da auch
angegriffen also es gibt verschiedene
Phänomene und ja es gibt hier ein
Problem mit Jugendgewalt und das gehen
wir an er hat sich vieles als nicht wahr
herausgestellt es lief sehr hoch im Netz
genau diese Behauptung es gab
tatsächlich auch in Leipzig in Connewitz
in der Nacht Ausschreitung von
linksextremen auch das fällt alles am
Ende in die Bilanz dieser Silvesternacht
rein und trotzdem haben sie auch gerade
gesagt Frau Ärger es waren so
überproportional viele beteiligt an
diesen Taten die eben ja kein deutschen
Pass haben ist man da immer noch
vorsichtig in Berlin genau das einmal zu
benennen um das dann entsprechend mit
den richtigen Maßnahmen anschließend
aufzuarbeiten also wir haben überhaupt
keine Angst über irgendwelche Sachen zu
benennen wir gucken uns die Fakten an
und überlegen dann wie wir die Menschen
erreichen und wie wir unsere Politik so
anpassen dass so etwas nicht mehr
passiert weil dass das zu verurteilen
dass da sind wir uns alle einig aber es
ist nicht überproportional das habe ich
ja eben gesagt es spielt genau die
Bevölkerungsdaten wieder die wir auch
vor Ort anfinden und ich glaube es ist
nicht richtig und das hat ja auch die
Bürgermeister klar genannt und damit hat
sich die CDU muss man sagen in Berlin
ziemlich isoliert um nach diesen
Vornamen zu fragen oder Stereotypen über
Menschen mit arabischen Hintergrund zu
verbreiten ich glaube das ist Wahlkampf
den wir so nicht machen sollen
diese Anfrage im Abgeordnetenhaus die
kam zu einer Zeit als man hier in Berlin
alles getan hat um nicht über die
richtigen Themen zu sprechen in den
ersten Tagen dieses Jahres haben wir
gesprochen über böllerverbote und
dergleichen mehr als ob damit die
Probleme hätten erledigt werden
von denen auch nicht deutschen Tätern
die Vornamen finden Sie das richtig also
jedenfalls muss man über die Fakten
sprechen und in den ersten Tagen in der
ersten Woche dieses Jahres hat man in
Berlin nicht über die Fakten gesprochen
dann gebe ich ihm mal kurz ein Faktum in
Berlin wird jede Stunde ein Polizist in
Dienst angegriffen nicht nur an
Silvester sondern jeder Stunde auf der
Straße das passiert deutschlandweit das
passiert Berlin haben sie angesprochen
vielleicht überproportional und
Silvester schon auch alle nach Berlin
sehen wir uns ehrlich wenn man es in
Freiburg passiert und am nächsten Tag in
Stuttgart redet keiner über
Baden-Württemberg aber in Berlin haben
wir halt ein Ballungszentrum da passiert
das sehr viel wir führen Debatten und
auch diese Vornamen Debatte kann man
führen und wir müssen über Jugendgewalt
sprechen wohlgemerkt in Berlin schon
seit über 15 Jahren ja und wir müssen
über Integration sprechen alles richtig
Herr Bali kommt auch gleich zu Wort aber
Fakt ist doch wir wissen aus der
silvestern kann nicht sagen über
proportional weil wir wissen es gar
nicht wenn ich ihn jetzt sage dass du
dein Festgenommenen z.B ein Australier
ist der am Brandenburger Torwart und
eine Sache Beschädigung begangen hat das
ist auch worüber reden wir denn dann
hier wir haben zu vielen dieser Taten
und da müssen wir schon über den
böllerverbot sprechen ganz einfach keine
Tatsachen weil die Kollegen draußen
überhaupt nicht gesehen haben wo die
Rakete hergefahren sehr viel und wir
haben noch kurz beenden wir haben unsere
Silvester eine Szenerie wo Leute die
Polizei die Feuerwehr angreifen wollen
gleichzeitig auch noch Waffen an die
Hand bekommen und in der Anonymität weil
ohnehin überall ganz viel fliegt und wie
ein Ballungsraum haben wo viel
Pyrotechnik im Umlauf ist erleichtern
wir stehen und setzen die
Sicherheitsbehörden gar nicht in die
Chance rein dann auch wirklich die Leute
festnehmen zu können und beweissicher
dann auch Verurteilung erreichen zu
können wir haben alle diese Videos
gesehen von der Silvester nachher Malik
sie auch es gibt das aus anderen
Großstädten auch das ist keine reines
kein reines Berlin Phänomen gewesen in
der Nacht und trotzdem haben diese
Videos besonders erschrocken was haben
sie auf diesem Video gesehen und wen
haben Sie dort also
ich habe auf den Videos in erster Linie
Menschen gesehen so ich finde diese
Taten die in Berlin gemacht worden die
sind abscheulich und unwirklich
hinterhältig da gibt's auch
da gibt es auch nichts zu sagen aber ich
finde es gefährlich wenn man jetzt
Jugendliche mit der jetzt die Arme
Migrationshintergrund haben so eine Art
Generalverdacht das kommt nämlich so
draußen so an bei den Jugendlichen ich
bin ja sehr nah dran bei den
Jugendlichen dass sie wieder sagen die
meinen alle uns und wir wissen natürlich
dass in dem Bezirken wo die Leute eher
in Sekretäre Lebenssituationen wo sie
auch wirklich wenig Teilhabe erfahren in
unsere Gesellschaft und die auch das
Gefühl haben nicht alle die Demokratie
die ist was für die Elite und dann wenig
Sozialarbeit oder wirklich politische
Bildung stattfindet dass man sagt ihr
gehört dazu die sind zum Teil in die
dritte Generationen deswegen ist mir
diese diese Debatte um den Pass die die
finde ich ein bisschen daneben weil es
geht um Menschen die die Taten gemacht
haben die sind diese Menschen die
gehören bestraft und die Menschen die da
drum rum sind die ganzen Jugendliche die
das mit beobachten die brauchen eine
ganz große Unterstützung Corona bin ich
kein wirklicher Sozialromantiker sondern
es geht mir auch darum wenn wir da
nichts tun längerfristig ist es auch so
dass es unsere Demokratie gefährdet wir
müssen die Leute dringend abholen und
jetzt machen wir schon seit 35 Jahre und
da ist es jetzt Edgar eskaliert wir
wollen einen Mann in die Runde holen der
in Berlin groß geworden ist zumindest ab
dem 5 lebensjahr der aus dem Libanon
gekommen ist mit ja libanesisch
syrischen Eltern sie sehen ihn schon
hier das ist nämlich ein echter
profi-box Champion mammutscher als bei
uns mit eben syrisch libanesischen
Wurzeln er kam im jungen Alter in den
Berliner Wedding und ist dann dort und
den Essen groß geworden ich grüße Sie
herzlich bei Bild die richtigen Fragen
an mammutscher sie kennen auch diese
Videos diese Gewaltvideos aus der
Silvester nach der Chart was sehen sie
dort und sehen sie dort
ich sehe ganz genau wie mein Kollege
gerade gesagt hat erstmal guten Tag aus
Dubai hast du beide mich zugeschaltet
das müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz
erklären dort bereiten Sie sich vor dort
trainieren Sie aktuell und deswegen die
lange Leitung dorthin
ganz genau
wie man sieht aber alles in Ordnung sehr
gerne die Zeit für euch ähm also mein
Kollegen der jetzt gerade zuletzt
gesprochen hat ganz genau ich sehe
Menschen in erster Dinge und ich sehe
nicht
integrations-probleme sondern ich sehe
gerade junge Menschen dieses zusammen
getan haben an diesem Abend und äh
Dummheiten
aber in erster Linie sage ich mal so man
muss das ja betrachten
bevor Silvester die Corona Debatte ich
meine Meinung ist die Corona Politik war
sehr streng bei uns man hätte den Jugend
lichen Platz wegnehmen sollen Sport
Sport baut ab aggress also ich bin immer
der Meinung dass Jugendliche wichtig
Sport machen müssen damit diese
Aggressionen aus dem Körper geht aus der
Seele weil die haben viel zu viel Zeit
die sitzen ihre Freizeit nur mit ihren
Handys Instagram Facebook und haben
überhaupt keine Freunde mehr die
Jugendlichen mehr die haben überhaupt
keine Ziele mehr wie investieren viel zu
viel Geld in im Ausland oder jetzt wie
zum Beispiel im Krieg anstatt in unsere
eigenen Land wir müssen eigentlich
erstmal unser eigenes Land im System für
die Jugendliche mehr Sportaktivitäten
mehr Sozialarbeiter fördern mehr mehr
politische zusammenbringen weil wir wir
verlangen immer das Integration was
heißt Integration beispielsweise
klingt wenn ich kurz dazwischen gehen
darf hat klingt jetzt fast so ein
bisschen so als seien die die
beispielsweise mit 15 Jahren
Feuerlöscher gegen fahrenden
Rettungswagen geworfen hat als ob das
ihren Meinung nach Opfer sein und nicht
zuerst Täter
ich habe ich betrachte ich werde jetzt
auch keine beschuldigen als Opfer das
ist nicht man hat aber ich rede einfach
die allgemeine Probleme bis angefangen
hat wenn Jugendliche nicht mehr Sport
machen dürfen in der corona-zeit dürften
die ja nicht mit Sport raus ich bin ja
komplett alle eingestellt Mann und jetzt
kommt dieses Silvester ab und dann
dürfen alle auf der Straße das sind
diese noch heute die tun sich zusammen
und dann kommt jetzt zum Beispiel die
Polizei in einer massengeburt die
Jugendlichen die kriegen Angst die tun
sich zusammen sie fühlen sich alles
zusammen als Verteidigung und was
passiert in einer aus dieser Jugendliche
ist Nummer der schwarze Schaf der
schmeiß den ersten Behörde macht die
erste Dummheit und dann ziehen alle mit
dass das Problem wenn die Polizei nicht
so
Gewalt aufgedrungen wäre meiner Meinung
nach sondern anders man hätte Gesprächen
sollen wer es nicht mal zu sagen
sind sie Schulter hier sind sie und ihre
ist sowieso nicht ich glaube Schuld ich
glaube ich möchte jetzt ja auch nicht
unterstellen dass sie wirklich Opfer und
Täter umkehrt aber eine Sache müssen wir
mal feststellen Herrscher also wir reden
über Jugendliche Heranwachsende Männer
die auch ganz offen sagen dass sie an
Silvester zusammenkommen können und mal
die Sau rauszulassen und den nazibullen
ist mal richtig zu geben da kann man
nachher immer noch zur Linken pro Jahr
weil das ist nämlich auch durchaus ein
Faktor den Herbst auch schon zu Recht
angesprochen hat politischen Berlin aber
Fakt ist schon wir reden hier auch von
Funkwagenbesatzung die teilweise
ungeschützt dort unterwegs waren an
einer Kreuzung und eingeflammt wurden
mit Pyrotechnik wir reden von
feuerwehrbesatzungen Herr Schah die
eingeteilt wurden ich weiß nicht wer die
Täter sind weil die waren vom Mund und
waren ganz schnell wieder weg ne das war
nicht alle offen aber fakt ist wir haben
es hier mit massiven Angriffen aus
Gruppen zu tun die wir das ja über immer
schon erleben und auch nicht nur an
dieser Silvester Nacht also wir können
die Schlagzeilen die letzten Jahre
angucken diese eine Szene die ich gerade
schon hat noch einmal anschauen kurze
jentro weil die so wahnsinnig im Kopf
bleibt die Szene in der ein 15-Jähriger
ein Feuerlöscher wirft auf ein ja
fahrenden Rettungswagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn Sie
wenn Sie das Sehen Herr frei diese
Szenen dort wenn Sie diese sehen Herrn
frei was glauben Sie was treibt ein
15-Jährigen um ein Feuerlöscher gegen
ein fahrenden Rettungswagen
also vor allen Dingen halte ich für
falsch hier von Dummheit zu reden das
ist ein absolut inakzeptables Verhalten
das darf ein Rechtsstaat auch nicht
durchgehen lassen und zwar egal wer es
war und ich glaube auch kann das
überhaupt dazu kommen
Informationen als 15-Jährigen sein diese
Tatsache ja da muss man eine ganze Reihe
von Fragen stellen das können
Integrationsfragen sein das können
Fragen sein wie man beispielsweise
sozialangebote macht aber das da dabei
darf man nicht stehen bleiben sondern
das Entscheidende ist gerade bei jungen
Leuten dass die Strafe auf den Fuß folgt
das ist etwas wo sehr schnell eine sehr
harte und konsequente Antwort des
Rechtsstaates in diesem Fall ja sehen
Sie und in Heilbronn beispielsweise ist
24 Stunden später jemand zu 9 Monaten
Haft vorurteilt worden das geht also
auch wenn Sie klare Verhältnisse haben
und des Personal interjustiz dieses
umsetzen kann einmal jetzt haben sie
auch noch mal dieses Mal diesen Fall
dieses Video gesehen sie kennen Jungs
und Mädels die in sehr jungem Alter auch
gewalttätig werden oder an der Schwelle
sind was fällt Ihnen bei solchen Szenen
ein warum macht das einer mit 15 Jahren
da muss man denn so da muss man in die
Tiefe gehen glaube ich weil ich glaube
da muss ganz ganz ganz viel rede ich sag
nun da sein und Wut auf irgendwelchen
Gründen das was der junge Mann da
gemacht hat das ist einfach nicht
entschuldbar aber es hat einen Grund
kein Mensch macht sowas einfach auf doof
da so da muss ein Hintergrund sein und
ich bin der Meinung dass wir jetzt dafür
sorgen müssen auch und das ganz schnell
dass diese Menschen die das gemacht
haben diese Taten auch nicht noch
Vorbilder für gewisse Menschen werden
die hinten dran stehen sondern wir
müssen gucken dass man die Jugendliche
die da auch leben die da aber nicht
dabei waren aber die Arbeit ohne
Situation sehen dass man den bei uns
eine echte Perspektive gibt weil das ist
für mich ein Widerspruch wir diskutieren
bundesweit Fachkräftemangel
und und unsere Republik ist sehr jung
die Frage ist doch warum landen diese
junge Potenziale nicht in die duale
Ausbildung was müssen wir als Brücke tun
dass sie kriegen verstehe ich alles oder
die Frage aber fragen wir fragen wir zu
viel was wir noch alles tun könnten was
möglicherweise im Kopf dieses
15-Jährigen gewesen ist als einfach zu
sagen so das ist wirklich weit weit über
die Grenze Frau erlaubt jetzt muss
erstmal sofort vor allen Dingen eines
Erfolgen der Rechtsstaat muss knallhart
durchgreifen also dass diese Taten
inakzeptabel sind und es dafür ein
rechtschreibliches Verfahren gehen muss
da sind sich alles eigentlich und das
läuft ja auch sehr nicht so als würden
die Behörden nicht arbeiten sondern es
gibt eine Abteilung die sich speziell
mit diesem Phänomen das übrigens sonst
beschäftigt sich die Abteilung mit
Hooligans bei Fußball spielen weil da
leider dieses Phänomen auch immer wieder
auftritt da kann die Polizei glaube ich
ein Lied von Singen und diese
Abteilungen
mittlerweile verurteilt sein Neuköllner
Modell
ich kenne mich gut aus mit dem
Neuköllner Modell das funktioniert eben
nur bei Straftaten und so ist auch das
beschleunigte Verfahren deswegen glaube
ich nicht dass das ein Jugendlicher oder
Heranwachsender war im Jugendstrafrecht
gibt es dieses beschleunigte Verfahren
nur bei Jugendarrest oder
Erziehungsmaßnahmen also bei sehr
geringen Sanktionen bei Jugendstrafe ist
das ausgeschlossen im JGG also ich habe
ja auch Jura studiert da steht drin und
insofern hier stehen ja aber so
wesentliche Straftaten im Raum dass auch
Jugendstrafen im Raum stehen deswegen
kommen diese beschleunigten Verfahren
überhaupt nicht in Betracht deswegen war
das sicherlich kein Jugendlicher aber da
heranwachsener deswegen ist gerade wenn
sowas wie Jugendstrafe droht ein
rechtsstaatliches ordentliches
gründliches Verfahren wichtig vor allem
wenn die Beweislage und das ist leider
oft so dass die Beweislage nicht völlig
klar ist
ständiges
ordentliches gründliches Verfahren immer
dass es Monate dauert nein also wir sind
sehr für ein sozusagen eine Folge direkt
auf dem Fuß so soll das folgen aber das
ist eben wie gesagt nur in den Grenzen
des Rechtsstaats möglich und da gibt es
klare Vorgaben bei Jugendlichen wenn man
Jugendstrafe verurteilen möchte dann
gibt es keine beschleunigtes Verfahren
so ist jetzt die Rechtslage und ich
denke das hat auch seine Gründe und
übrigens möchte ich noch mal was dazu
sagen zu diesem böllerverbot weil gesagt
oder wurde über die falschen Sachen
gesprochen ich muss sagen also das
Böller Verkaufsverbot das ist gegeben
hat während der Jahre der
corona-pandemie hat dazu geführt dass es
weniger Übergriffe auf Einsatzkräfte und
so weitergegeben haben damit keine
Gewalt auf den Straßen gibt nein es ging
um beim Böller Verkaufsverbot das ist
nicht gegen die Menschen die es kaufen
sondern es ist vor allem
verhindert das tat Gelegenheiten
geschafft werden auch
Schreckschusswaffen sind frei verfügbar
verstehe ich nicht das kann man auch
koppeln an Einschränkungen deswegen sind
wir als LINKE führen Verkaufsverbot weil
das Zitat Gelegenheiten reduziert
darüber machen
beispielsweise also die Frage ist ja
immer was tut man wo schenkt man
Freiheiten ein was sind die
Kollateralschäden darüber muss man sich
ja unterhalten aber was mir auch wichtig
ist zu sagen sie haben gefragt Herr
Weise ob es immer so lange gehen muss
nein muss es natürlich nicht wenn die
Stellen für Richter und Staatsanwälte
besetzt sind wie in anderen Ländern aber
in Berlin eben nicht wenn wir eine
Polizei haben die entsprechend
ausgestattet ist ich gebe Ihnen eine
Beispiel die 30.000 Polizistinnen und
Polizistinnen Berlin haben 250 bodycams
in Baden-Württemberg hat jeder
Streifenpolizist eine in anderen Ländern
ist es ganz ähnlich das heißt wir haben
schon ganz unterschiedliche
Voraussetzungen und der rechtssta kein
einziges Tat verhindert leider nein
genau
Respekt vor dem Beamten mehr Respekt
diese Taten verhindert hat sie wissen
wie es auf der Straße zugeht wie sie
wissen genau wie in diesen Vierteln
gesprochen wird wie viel Respekt hat man
vor den deutschen Polizisten
in erster Linie ich glaube schon dass
die Jugendlichen Respekt haben vor der
Polizei die haben schon Respekt aber in
so ein Abend wenn die sich zusammentun
dann fühlen die sich mit mutig und dann
machen sie Dummheiten das sind einfach
Jugendliche die einfach zu viel Freizeit
haben im Leben und nicht wissen mit
ihrer Zukunft anzufangen
ich sage ja immer so warum ist der
Mensch dazu in der Lage sowas zu machen
also ich bin auf jeden Fall dagegen es
ist nicht gut was in Berlin passiert ist
und auch auf jeden Fall was gegen die
Feuerwehr passiert ist oder gegen die
Polizei aber was hat sie dazu geführt
ich will meiner Meinung ist die Gruppe
und der aufmerk der Polizei hat sie
zusammen mobilisiert durch die Angst
dass sie so reagiert haben die haben
psychische psychologisch quasi sich
zusammengetan und aus Angst Dummheiten
gemacht hätte der
Fraktionschef von Parteichef der von
cdu/csu bzw der cdu-parteivorsitzende
Friedrich Merz der hat auch diese
Debatte geführt und der hat ein ganz
klares Wort benannt für diejenigen die
dort seiner Meinung nach auf der Straße
waren hören wir noch mal ganz kurz rein
sprechen Sie mal mit Lehrerinnen und
Lehrern in den Grundschulen was die
jeden Tag erleben auch an verbaler
Gewalt und dann wollen Sie diese Kinder
zur Ordnung rufen und die Folge ist dass
die Väter in den Schulen erscheinen und
sich das verbitten insbesondere wenn es
sich um Lehrerinnen handelt dass sie
ihre Söhne die kleinen Paschas da mal
etwas
zurechtweisen da fängt es an
der CDU und CSU Fraktion Chef Friedrich
Merz über diejenigen die seine Meinung
nach eben kein Respekt vom Rechtsstaat
haben in dem Fall vor den Lehrern vor
den vor allen Dingen Lehrerinnen haben
er frei bei uns im Studio der Kollege
von Friedrich Merz hier auf diesem Stuhl
hat er recht damit mit diesem Begriff
auch Paschas also jedenfalls hat
Friedrich Merz einen Sachverhalt
beschrieben der bedauerlicherweise in
Deutschland Realität ist denn ich möchte
es noch mal sagen es geht hier nicht um
Dummheiten es geht um fehlenden Respekt
vor den Sicherheitskräften auch vor den
Institutionen unseres Staates und es hat
natürlich in vielen Fällen schon etwas
auch mit Integration zu tun genau diesen
Respekt zu haben übrigens den Respekt
nicht nur vor den Institutionen sondern
beispielsweise auch vor Polizistinnen
oder vor Lehrerinnen weil man das anders
gelernt hat sagt Friedrich Merz Manuel
mammutschar Paschas sagt der Friedrich
Merz da bei meinem Kollegen Markus Lanz
sind sie ein Pascha
allein die Aussage ist doch schon falsch
also es tut mir leid wir reden
reden
[Musik]
sie sich beleidigt dadurch ich kann mich
erinnern dass in der U-Bahn ganz andere
Begriffe fallen hier in Berlin
das ist die Straße das ist das Leben so
wie die Jugendlichen aufgewachsen sind
wenn man ich bin ja damals 1989 nach
Deutschland eingelassen Flüchtling
damals hatte ich nicht die Möglichkeit
gehabt die heute die Flüchtlinge so ein
gutes Leben zu haben direkt eine
Ausbildung zu machen schulische Hilfe
und alles damals war die Politik noch
sehr streng und anders damals
verlassen
wollte ein anderes Bundesland
einreisen möchte braucht jemand
Erlaubnis das hat mich sehr sehr schwer
behindert in meiner sportlichen Karriere
ja ich als ich Kickboxen war ich wollte
damals keine Angst Turniere mitteilen in
Europa weil ich keine Ausweis hatte auch
als Profi Boxer wurde es mir sehr sehr
schwer gemacht ich bin trotzdem
geblieben auch wenn ich wirklich
schwere Zeiten hat leben oder auch mit
falsche Menschen oder Gruppen Umgang
bin ich trotzdem
dahin gebracht wo ich heute bin von der
Straße
weil sie ärgert noch einmal dieses Wort
vom Pascha Herrscher gibt Situationen in
ihrer Kindheit in der Schulzeit mit der
Lehrerin oder auf der Straße mit
Polizistin wo sie sicher erinnern sie
selber haben auch Kontakt mit der
Polizei immer wieder mal gehabt dass sie
sich ein bisschen ertappt fühlen in dem
was Friedrich Merz sagt und sagen ja mit
mist da habe ich nicht ausreichend
Respekt gehabt
nein ich habe ich habe immer Respekt vor
der Polizei gehabt auch wenn ich
Dummheiten gemacht habe selber als
Jugendlicher ich war nicht frech also
ich habe nie beleidigt oder
aggressiv geworden so wirklich
erwischen das habe ich dann eingegeben
das ist meine Art die Art in Berlin ich
weiß nicht wie das dort läuft aber ich
kann für mich sprechen ich war niemals
Gesicht zur Polizisten wollen wir
sprechen darüber das hat hat Herr Merz
damit ansprechen wollen ganz offenbar
dieses Problem dass dort Kinder
Jugendliche sind die aus ihrer Familie
durch ihre Herkunft ganz andere
Erfahrungen mit Sicherheitskräften
gemacht haben Erfahrungen die wir hier
in Deutschland auf keinen Fall machen
wollen wo die Polizei wo das Militär
viel härter viel brutaler durchgreift
können Sie da verstehen dass man weniger
Respekt hat vor den Kollegen von Herrn
Endrohr wenn die Polizei erstmal
dskalieren beispielsweise Auftritt also
dass man eben diesen Respekt eben nicht
lebt auf den Straßen also ich glaube
dass diese Debatte gerade mit Pascha und
diese das ist für mich ablenkungsdebatte
und mit einem klaren rassistischen
Einschlag und selbst Lindner hat sich
von diesen Äußerungen distanziert und
gesagt die CDU ist deswegen nicht
regierungsfähig die Grünen haben sich
hier gesagt sie werden keine Koalition
mit der CDU eingehen aufgrund dieser
Debatten ich finde wir sollten schon
über die richtigen Sachen sprechen und
jetzt nicht irgendwelche
ablenkungsdebatten führen also mein Sohn
beispielsweise hört das
respektloses Verhalten gegenüber
Lehrerin von allen möglichen
Schülerinnen und das liegt nicht also
dieses Problem sozusagen zu ethnisieren
finde ich falsch ja also das ist kein
ethnisch begründetes Problem das ist
einfach es gibt ein Problem natürlich
mit Menschen auch Familien die
überfordert sind die sich nicht
ausreichend vielleicht um den Kindern
nicht ausreichend die Möglichkeiten
geben und Bildungschancen und so weiter
also wir haben deine ganze Menge
Probleme und das hat sicher auch was mit
Respekt zu tun und ich finde wenn wir
wollen und wir wollen das ist mehr
Respekt gibt vor der Demokratie und
staatlichen Einrichtungen dann müssen
wir Projekte Stärken wie Gewalt
koalitionsprojekte das machen wir
übrigens in Berlin mit der
Landeskommission gegen Gewalt wir müssen
Sozialarbeit stärken und all diese
Sachen und es geht auch darum dass
Menschen beispielsweise das ist jetzt
keine täteropfer Umkehr oder irgendeine
Verharmlosung ganz sicher nicht aber man
muss sich die Ursachen angucken und es
gibt Menschen die haben beispielsweise
kein Vertrauen oder ein Misstrauen
instrukturen weil sie merken dass sie
benachteiligt und ausgegrenzt werden das
zeigen dieser Studien das
kinderausnahmen Familie und Nachteile zu
lassen ich glaube niemanden Tisch möchte
hier die Sozialarbeit
vermissen lassen wir haben einen Gipfel
gegen Jugend Gewalt gemacht Franziska
Giffey hat dazu eingeladen und das
festgestellt worden nein wir haben
verabredet dass wir Millionen wieder wir
haben ja schon Sozialarbeit in meinem
Wahlkreis kann ich nur empfehlen Gangway
die machen ganz tolle Straßen
Sozialarbeit
und es gibt Projekte und das ist eine
Verabredung noch etwas zu tun
möglicherweise nach der Wahl ja gut wir
haben ja erste Schritte also er
beispielsweise es ging vorhin um just
schnelle Verfahren unter Rot-Grün-Rot
wurden am meisten Personal in der Justiz
eingestellt wie jemals zuvor auch nicht
unter einer CDU mit Regierung ich will
sagen wir tun ganz viel und wir tun auch
aktuell viel die Verfahren laufen es
gibt viel Präventionsarbeit aber wir
wollen sie stärken man muss auch immer
Sachen reden das ist der erstmal muss
ich sagen es vermischt sich sehr sehr
viel und wir können gerne Pascha Debatte
führen und wir müssen auch darüber
sprechen dass es vermehrt auch unter dem
Jahr zu Angriffen aus Jugendgruppen gibt
auch oftmals mit Migrationshintergrund
das haben wir auch im Steinmetz vor
Halloween alles gut passt ja noch einmal
ganz kurz sie sind weiter daran
dass Herr März damit ausdrücken wollte
ganz offenbar es geht hier um Respekt es
geht um mangelnden Respekt
da komme ich jetzt den vor ihrer
vollkommen recht das hatte im übrigen
aber hat die Berliner CDU in den Jahren
als in Regierung Verantwortung war auch
nicht gebucht bekommen ja die Probleme
die wir heute haben die sind nicht erst
unter rot grün rot oder rot grün
entstanden sondern die sind schon Jahre
vorher gewachsen was uns ein bisschen
stört es wir machen jetzt ein
Jugendgewalt Gipfel schön bisschen
Schnittchen Essen super die Probleme
kennen wir seit 15 Jahren und wir wissen
auch was wir tun müssen wenn wir darüber
reden dass jetzt nach Silvester die
Strafen ganz schnell kommen müssen wegen
Gewalt gegen Einsatzkräfte bin ich als
Gewerkschafter der für Polizistinnen und
Polizisten und Feuerwehrleute spricht
voll mit dabei aber darauf hat auch eine
Frau unter dem Jahr den Anspruch die
Opfer einer häuslichen Gewalt wurde und
das passiert eben auch nicht und wenn
wir darüber reden wir möchten die
sozialarbeitstärken also Frau Irlands
aus Neukölln oder Friedrichshain
Kreuzberg wir können ja mal gucken wie
in den Bezirken wie viele Stellen für
Sozialarbeiter leer sind weil wir die
Leute gar nicht finden und noch mal Herr
Schah riesen Respekt ja was die
Boxkarriere angeht aber Fakt ist in
Deutschland gibt's auch keine
Friedensrichter ja und sie haben sich
auch schon mal hingestellt und wollten
vermitteln im Bereich der organisierten
Kriminalität das heißt wenn wir über
Respekt reden und das ist auch ein
Faktor die greifen Menschen an Polizei
und Feuerwehr zum einen weil sie die
greifen können anders als in der frei
ich hoffe nicht dass sie angegriffen
werden aber sie sind Bundespolitiker in
Verantwortung an den kann ich meinen
Frust nicht ablassen an den
Sicherheitskräften die auf der Straße
sind schon und bei der Rechtsstaat und
da sind wir bei dem Faktor dann wenn wir
über junge Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund oder Ausländer an
sich sprechen in vielen Heimatländern
wird für verhältnismäßig kleinere
Delikte eben viel härter abgestraft und
das ist Neuköllns und Kreuzbergs oder im
Wedding möglicherweise hier Scharia mehr
gilt als der Rechtsstaat der deutschen
mittlerweile wissen sie am 6.07 wurde in
Hellersdorf ein Böller aus dem Balkon
geschmissen das war niemand mit
Migrationshintergrund ja wir haben
während der corona-zeit
die Frage ist ob es schlimmer geworden
ist und ich glaube während jemand sagt
dass es keine deutschen wir reden jetzt
darüber aber während der coronazeit
haben wir die diverse Angriffe aus
Gruppen in Parks gehabt wo junge Leute
zusammengekommen sind ja jetzt kann man
sagen ja die durften ja während der
coronazeit nichts machen ne aber Fakt
ist die kriegen Alkohol die konsumieren
drogenakter ist ein Polizist nach dem
schmeiße ich jetzt mal voll so und den
attackiert das heißt wir müssen schon
die Debatte führen über was was ihr
eigentlich Silvester passiert ist und
wir reden nur darüber weil wir Bilder
sehen wie Einsatzkräfte angegriffen
werden also reden wir mal darüber wie
war das verbessern können und da geht's
um starken Rechtsstaat da geht so ein
Respekt und es geht aber auch wie lebe
ich das als Politik vor Stärke ich
meiner polizeil den Rücken oder mache
ich bei jedem Fehlverhalten such
wirklich nach dem absoluten Fehler und
macht dann Generalverdacht wir wollen
nicht ein Generalverdacht über junge
Leute mit Migrationshintergrund Stellen
ich erwarte aber auch das nicht alle
Beschäftigten der Polizei in Berlin in
eine Schublade gesteckt werden wenn sich
mal einer daneben benimmt und genau das
passiert ich meine wir haben ein
landesdiskriminierungsgesetz in Berlin
das ist sonst anderen
und da wird werden die Polizisten
natürlich unter Generalverdacht gestellt
und müssen sozusagen im Wege der
Beweislastumkehr nachweisen dass sie
nicht diskriminiert haben das ist etwas
was absolut indiskutabel ist und was im
Grunde genommen einfach nur zeigt dass
man denen die eigentlich für Recht und
Ordnung sorgen mit Misstrauen begeht
ist natürlich auch dazu dass man dass
man staatliche Institutionen nicht ernst
nimmt er zeigt den Finger schon ja ich
kriege die ganze Zeit von hier ein
bisschen rum es ist schon ein bisschen
gefährlich diese Debatte momentan führt
weiche das mit dem Migrationshintergrund
und Täter und was momentan auch warum
ist das gefährlich weil mir genau den
Leuten zuarbeiten mit dieser Debatte die
eben Probleme mit unserer Demokratie
haben die kriegen dann auch noch recht
glauben sie dass sie gar nicht einmalig
ich glaube wir haben ja jetzt gar nicht
darüber gesprochen
aber das ist die Tendenz die die
Jugendliche erleben so das ist die
Tendenz es gibt jetzt diesen
Generalverdacht und da denke ich mal wer
wer führt diesen Generalverdacht ich
höre immer das Wort von von ihrer Seite
und ich habe niemanden gehört der diesen
generalverkehr in den vergangenen
deutschen beschuldigt man muss mal
gucken
hoffentlich in Deutschland oder was ist
das Problem also warum fragt man nach
den Vornamen ich habe das doch gerade
vorhin gesagt man muss es immer im
Kontext für uns immer im Kontext der
Zeit sehen und damals hat man über die
falschen Themen gesprochen dieser Antrag
hat schon den Zweck gedient Transparenz
in die Debatte zu bringen
sagen die Berliner CDU hat ja selber
eingesehen Herr Freitag das Problem ist
natürlich die Frage ergibt nur Sinn wenn
ich die Antwort bekomme die ich vorher
möchte und wir müssen aufpassen schaffen
wir populistisch rassistische
Ressentiments und das ist passiert wenn
ich mit der CDU in Berlin spreche und
man hat selber eingesehen
haben Moment ich sag den tatverdächt den
Namen und dann sage ich never Jason
wissen Sie was dann kommt da kommt nicht
machen war auch keiner aus Hellersdorf
Marzahn waren Touristen sehen
irgendetwas nicht passt dann spricht man
sofort von rassistisch Rassismus doch
auf der anderen Seite auch keine schönen
Malerei wie es auch und auf der anderen
Seite passiert die einen sagen ja das
ist eine wir müssen eine Debatte über
Migranten finden die anderen sagen die
sind nicht Migranten alles schön
sprechen über das was wir wissen das
machen wir sachlich nur dazu was sie
gerade Generalverdacht haben dass die
Berliner Polizei jetzt so eine Art
sprachknicke an die Hand bekommen wird
in dem auch drin dass man von Südländer
nicht mehr nein nein nein mein Bestes
nicht weil ich habe beobachtet was in
den sozialen Medien los war und wie sich
von heute auf morgen die Sprache
verändert hat
völlig unkommentiert und das habe ich
für gefährlich nicht dass man gegen
Rassismus und so sondern einfach ich
finde es gefährlich wenn man so eine
Stimmung aufbaut das App jetzt ein
bisschen ab aber die erste Zeit das hat
mich richtig erschreckt auch Leute wo es
erstmal nicht für vermutet habe und ich
bin Verfechter davon zahlen jetzt müssen
wir doch mal das nutzen und gucken nach
vorne und ein bisschen gucken wie kann
überhaupt sowas passieren das entstanden
das tun wir auch ich möchte abschließen
verstehen nämlich auch hier habt ihr
tatsächlich auf dem Weg da hin sind
etwas zu verschweigen weil wir sorgen
haben eine größere Gruppe hier
beispielsweise in Berlin oder in anderen
Großstädten an einem Generalverdacht
auszusprechen für das dazu dass wir hier
in der Runde bestimmte Probleme
bestimmte Tatsachen ich benennen falsch
weil es wird ja über gesprochen also
das sollten wir jetzt nicht benennen die
Pässe sollten über die Ursachen wenn wir
wirklichen Interesse daran haben um die
Ursachen zu bekämpfen damit sowas nicht
wieder passiert dann müssen wir halt
auch die Probleme ansprechen die
existieren und die liegen eben in vielen
anderen Bereichen viel stärker weil es
waren sozial benachteiligte Quartiere
die betroffen sind und ich möchte gerne
einmal etwas zum Landesamt die
Diskriminierungsgesetz sagen und sie
nannten es sprachkleege also das Polizei
keine diskriminierende Sprache verwendet
ist doch selbstverständlich dass wir das
erwarten und es ist doch gut wenn
Polizei an sich arbeitet und es stärkt
doch das Vertrauen das ist doch kein
Generalvertrag es stärkt das Vertrauen
und das ist übrigens eine Forderung von
nicht Regierungsorganisation genauso wie
die Kennzeichnungspflicht wo sie sich
gegengewandt haben es stärkt das
Vertrauen in Demokratie und Recht hat
wenn es auch einen Kontrollmechanismus
gibt das ist ganz normale in unserer
Demokratie und in dem Rechtsstaat und
das ist gut und das verbessert die
Strukturen stärkt das Vertrauen stärkt
den Respekt und das ist doch was woran
man arbeiten muss
kontrollinstitutionen wir sind ein
Rechtsstaat da gibt's überhaupt kein
defiz und jetzt müssen sie mal sehen
weil das Diskriminierung
diskriminierungsfreie Sprache sondern da
geht es um das was sie darunter
verstehen ich finde die PolizistInnen
Polizisten sollten so reden wie man hier
bei uns eben redet unverstellt und
unkünstlich und so dass es die dies
angeht auch verstehen das heißt sie
beschäftigen sie beschäftigen
Probleme sind sie sollten gerade im
Bereich der inneren Sicherheit sich um
die wirklichen Themen kümmern da gibt es
ein Defizit beim Senat in Berlin ich
möchte wir Streit weiter übertragen sie
machen Spaß Polizei Verehrungen
so weiter hier in Deutschland vor allem
Verantwortung vor der nächsten
Generation genau
darüber streiten wir gleich weiter hier
in dieser Runde mit dem was man hat
es ist Politik
[Musik]
in Deutschland wie groß ist das Problem
der straßengewaltschaft und Gewalt und
was hat das auch zu tun mit Migration
das diskutieren wir hier in dieser Runde
hier bei Bild wir haben Bilder gesehen
aus der Silvesternacht wir haben aber
danach brutale prügelvideos hermalig
gesehen der Sozialarbeiter in Offenbach
unterwegs ist auch aus Rastatt
beispielsweise aus Karlsruhe Mädchen
dort
überraschenderweise muss man sagen
Mädchen die brutal zugeschlagen haben
noch auf ihre Opfer getreten haben hier
sehen wir dieses sehen als die bereits
am Boden lagen und das erschreckende
diese Szenen dann auch ja zum Angeben
stolz ins Netz gestellt haben einmalig
erklären Sie mir das ich kenne das ganz
ehrlich überhaupt nicht aus meiner
Jugend solche
brutalsten Szenen was muss in dem Moment
in den Köpfen derer Vorgehen die immer
noch mal und nochmal zutreten erstmal
glaube ich dass wir in unsere
Gesellschaft momentan ein echtes
Gewaltproblem haben das hängt er nicht
mit etien oder irgendwelche Herkunft wir
haben ein echtes Gewaltproblem das sehe
ich auch und und ich sehe auch dass es
Gruppen gibt da ist die Hemmschwelle
gerade jetzt mit den neuen Netzwerken
wann ist cool und so die ist nach unten
gegangen
mein Ansatz ist ist dann eher dass man
nicht über die Leute redet sondern mit
den Leuten redet was ist mit dir
passiert dass du überhaupt sowas
unmenschliches machst da muss doch
irgendwie eine Hemmschwelle überbrochen
sein Kommen Sie dafür antworten wenn Sie
beispielsweise bei solchen Täterin
nachfragen wie konnte das ich hatte bis
jetzt mit solchen Täterinnen und Täter
immer einen ganzen Berufsleben doch nie
zu tun gehabt mit dieser Brutalität das
hatte ich noch nicht es gab früher jetzt
auch in meiner Jugend da gab es immer da
gab es die blaue Jacken die schwarze ja
da gab es diese Gang Geschichte und so
das war eine Jugendszene schon immer
Thema aber diese Brutalität habe ich
jetzt selber im Jugendzentrum oder so
oder jetzt oder jetzt immer ein Umfeld
in Offenbach habe ich so exzessiv noch
nicht ich habe viel davon gehört ich
habe doch den einen oder anderen mal
mitbekommen und das war das und das war
so das da waren junger Mann der hat ein
Problem gehabt und der hat bei uns im
Boxen Arbeit Aufladen gemacht und jetzt
war das gut weil der hat bei uns eine
ganz Kamera Ansage gekriegt der so und
der war auch dann bei uns im Training
weil bei uns läuft es so wer bei uns ins
Training kommt da wollen wir die
Zeugnisse sehen wer in irgendein Fach
schlechter ist wie viel der muss in die
Nachhilfe und bei ihm war das
Schulversagen und das war das eigentlich
wo er kommunizieren und dann in der
Gruppe cool sein wollte und und nun war
genau das Ding und dann hat der junge
Mann auch gesagt die haben von mir
Respekt und dann habe ich gesagt die
haben vor dir Angst Respekt ist was ganz
anderes warum hast du von mir Respekt
ich kann dir kaum auf dem Bauchnabel
gucken wegen mein Bestes und dann sagt
der junge Mann ja weil du hilfst und du
machst gutes Lager das ist Respekt alles
andere und da muss man mit den Leuten
reden und es tut auch manchmal weh und
da gibt's dann manchmal Niederlagen die
man in unserem Beruf aushalten muss aber
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass man genau
diese Themen es gibt ja viele Projekte
die die Jugendlichen da ist mittlerweile
abholen so und es ist und und und ich
habe manchmal das Gefühl dass die
das ist da gibt es einfach Leute das ist
einfach für die wie Kino das Wetter
wenn wir diese Szenen sehen hier
interessiert sind vielleicht an der
Polizeiarbeit noch einen Tick mehr dran
sie kennen solche oder ähnliche Szenen
aus Berlin was muss in den Momenten in
den Köpfen derer Vorgehen die eben noch
mal und noch mal zutreten
müssen sie diejenigen Fragen die das
machen ich meine wer Menschen die am
Boden liegen gegen Kopf tritt nimmt
nicht nur schwer zu Verletzungen sondern
auch den Tod einer Personen kaufen von
früher nicht habe ihn aber auch ehrlich
sagen mein Freund wurde von einem Nazi
genau vor mir genau auf diese Art und
Weise verprügelt in meiner Jugend möchte
eine Sache sagen dass er der Ciao
korrekterweise auch von richtig
angesprochen und auch einmalig gerade
wir haben durchaus schon Werteverlust da
gegen das Jahr nicht mehr mit Menschen
reden ja dass wir auch Respekt vor
Menschen nicht mehr haben weil wir ihn
gar nicht mehr begegnen wir ziehen uns
in Social Media zurück das sind heutige
Gegebenheiten diese Bilder hätten sie
auch vor 20 25 Jahren bekommen wenn es
die Möglichkeit gegeben hätte also wir
müssen auch ehrlich sein wir haben heute
viel mehr Bilder davon aber das nicht
die Frage die wir uns hier stellen
müssen sondern die Frage ist und
deswegen bin ich hier warum ist die
Gewalt gegen Einsatzkräfte in den
letzten Jahren hoch wir haben auch an
Silvester nicht darüber gesprochen dass
auch Menschen von Raketen verletzt
wurden die nicht der Polizei oder
Feuerwehr ne aber wir müssen darüber
reden und Frau hat hier in
Regierungsverantwortung in Berlin ist ja
DIE LINKE es wurde eine Studienauftrag
gegeben die sich auch die Berliner
Polizei angucken sollte das kann jetzt
als Misstrauen sehen ich achtet relativ
sachlich gesehen schauen wir uns noch
mal an da wird nämlich rauskommen dass
wir eine sehr bürgerfreundliche Berliner
Polizei haben dass die sehr viel Macht
und wir haben auch viel über
Hilfsorganisationen gesprochen nicht
staatlich Organisation
interessanterweise diejenigen die
Menschen beraten sollen die ohnehin
Problem mit dem Rechtsstaat haben die
sich nicht aufgenommen fühlen die wissen
manchmal gar nicht was sind eigentlich
staatlich Auftrag der Polizei das ist
nämlich in ihrer Studie darauf gekommen
und das sollte uns zu denken geben dass
wir gar nicht mehr wissen was müssen
eigentlich recht staatliche
rechtsstaatliche Aufgaben sein was muss
die Polizei eigentlich tun wir reden
immer über Polizei Gewalt ja Polizei ist
die einzige Organisation die Gewalt
gesetzmäßig anwenden darf natürlich
nicht rechtswidrig aber jeder nach einer
Demo hier Friedrich sein Kreuzberg sagt
hier Polizei gewaltig schlagen auf einen
keiner weiß was die eigentlich machen
müssen und jetzt sind wir kurz bei dem
Fall mit der syrischen Familie den sie
ansprechen der Kollege hat vollkommen
falsche Kommunikation gewesen möchte ich
überhaupt nicht schön reden ja aber
Moment muss ich noch mal ganz kurz
erklären
mein Video das im Netz kursierte das
zeigt einen Ausschnitt eines Einsatzes
der Berliner Polizei genau in einer
Wohnung die Kollegen waren da
die Kollegen waren da um einem
Haftbefehl zu vollstrecken ja weil ein
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe nicht bezahlt
wurde und das passiert dann hat sich da
ordentlich im Ton vergriffen
wurde ich voll unterschreiben aber und
jetzt sind wir bei einem wichtigen Punkt
was macht denn dann eine Partei in
Regierungsverantwortung in Berlin sie
veranstaltet eine Pressekonferenz und
lässt die Familie da einfach Ihre Sicht
von sich geben das schauen sich dann
nämlich auch ganz viele syrische
Familien an es ist ein rechtsstaatliches
vorgehen dass genau geguckt wird hat der
Kollege richtig gehandelt ja nein das
disziplinarrechtliche Maßnahmen
eingeleitet werden ja nein aber was
senden sie denn für ein Signal sie geben
eine Moment und wir sind bei den
Hilfsorganisationen und die Studie hat
es deutlich gesagt sehr sehr kleinen
Gruppen aber eine Sache noch bitte in
Ordnung nein aber wenn sie sprechen dass
die Berliner Polizei zumindest in Teilen
ganz offenbar ja sich von der Politik
hier in Berlin vernachlässigt fühlt
können sie es verstehen nein das wurde
uns auch so nicht mitgeteilt ehrlich
gesagt wir sind ja regelmäßig im
Austausch also dass wir
wie gesagt schon relativ lange relativ
gut zu und ich höre auch das was viele
Beamte auf der Straße sagen und die vor
allen Dingen die sich dort in der
Silvesternacht ja die brutal angegriffen
wurden die fühlen sich nicht gestützt
von ihnen durch was denn also es gibt
Gesetze die sie schützen es gibt wir
haben sehr viel gekümmert um bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen das haben wir auch
zum Teil erreicht wir haben uns darum
gekümmert dass mehr Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte in die Polizei
gehen und so weiter also es wurde sehr
viel gemacht aber ob jetzt bodycams der
richtige weg sind oder nicht da gibt es
eben Diskussionen das muss man
wissenschaftlich evaluieren das machen
wir jetzt auch aber es gibt natürlich
viele Sachen sich die Polizei wünscht
alles sofort unterschreiben sondern es
muss kritisch überprüft werden dieses
Video wie gesagt das zeigte nur ein
Ausschnitt dieses Einsatz und sie und
sie laden anschließend die syrische
Familie vor und lassen die erzählen und
der Polizist durfte sein Sachverhalt
aber nicht erklären ist das die Sache
wie sie Gewichten jeder darf seine
Sachverhalt erklären wenn er das möchte
es ging uns als Linke darum dass diese
Menschen auch mal gehört werden weil der
Zugang den Menschen die die Sprache
nicht gut sprechen die vielleicht erst
hier sind wissen sie hat mit dieser
Familie gesprochen dieses Tochter die
dabei war die schwer traumatisiert warum
hat diese Familie kein Recht ihre
Perspektive
ermöglicht dass sie das auch mal sagen
kann weil überall wird nur über sie
gesprochen über die Polizeibeamten
gesprochen warum kann diese Familie
nicht auch sozusagen gehört werden ich
finde das gehört dazu und das ist ihr
gutes Recht übrigens da war ich gerade
letzte Woche beim Prozess äh hat das
auch gemacht die ist nämlich verprügelt
worden auch gleiche Szene leider auch
Frauen ja die auf sie eingeschlagen sind
rechtsradikales Milieu oder irgendwie
rechts offenes Milieu und die die
Landwirte hat vom Krankenhaus noch mit
Instagram gefilmt und ihre Perspektive
in die Welt gebracht das hat überhaupt
erst in Gang gebracht dass es dieses
Verfahren gab anzeigen und so weiter und
dass ich darum gestellt wird
und das ist doch wichtig
weil wir wir sehen brutale Angriffe in
der silvestern
den ersten Tagen danach die Berliner
Polizei hat das gemacht auch bestimmte
Tätergruppen und dann drei Wochen später
sitzen wir hier vertreten auch durch die
Berliner Politik und sprechen über eine
syrische Familie die verbale
Polizeigewalt erlebt hat wir sprechen
überforderngriffe ist natürlich gibt von
Rechtsradikalen verläuft diese Debatte
ein Stück weit sinnbildlich für ähnliche
Debatten in den vergangenen Jahren immer
wieder die die Politik geführt hat
nee wir reden ja über alle möglichen
Formen von Gewalt auch von reichsbürgern
von Rechtsextremisten wir reden über
Kriminalität von politischen Aktivisten
die beispielsweise in Lutzerath Gesetz
brechen und auch Polizisten angreifen
also Gewalt gibt es natürlich in
unterschiedlichen Formen und
unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen aber
eines scheint mir schon wichtig ich
kenne jetzt den konkreten Fall in Berlin
nicht wir haben das in lützerat auch
erlebt und wir erleben das in solchen
Fällen auch immer als ob hier von zwei
gleichberechtigten auszugehen wäre wir
haben auf der einen Seite eine Polizei
die Recht und Gesetz durchsetzt die auch
unmittelbaren Zwang anwenden darf um
Recht und Gesetz durchzusetzen wenn dem
anderweitig nicht Genüge getan wird und
wir haben auf der anderen Seite
Rechtsbrecher und insofern ist
vollkommen klar da braucht kein
Austausch von Argumenten sondern wenn es
eine richterliche Entscheidung gibt oder
wenn die Gesetzeslage klar ist dann ist
dem nachzukommen und wenn das nicht
passiert dann macht es die Polizei
Partei mit unmittelbarem Zwang von allen
Seiten denn das gehört natürlich
tatsächlich zu dem vollständigen Bild
lützerath haben sie gerade angesprochen
und diese Szenen die sich dort
abspielten die haben sich in Teilen
überhaupt nicht unterschieden von dem
was in der Silvesternacht passiert auch
Angriffe mit Pyrotechnik mit
Molotow-Cocktails auf ihre beamtentro
also wo bleibt da der Unterschied also
erstmal möchte ich mal ganz kurz was
sagen das hat der frei schon gut
angesprochen auch da weil ich eben
meinte man gibt Einzelnen die
Möglichkeit sehr sehr viel rauszutragen
ich habe auch bei Mütze Rad die Magie
wissen kann man sie ja nennen aber
letztlich wenn man Steine schmeißt auf
Menschen ist mein strafze
Polizei Aufgebot hier völlig
unverhältnismäßig und die Polizei macht
sich zum würde von RWE das ist eine
politische Entscheidung die
oberinstanzlich juristisch aus so also
ausdiskutiert ist da gibt's keinen
führen wieder mehr das ist jetzt nicht
wie im Hambacher Forst vor ein paar
Jahren ja sondern es ist klar was mit
diesem Gelände passiert und die Polizei
hatte im Rahmen der Amtshilfe dort
Sicherheit zu sorgen und wenn ich sehe
das schon vor der Räumungen lützerat
Steine Flaschen auf ein
Kommunikationsteam der Polizei
geschmissen werden das sind Leute die
haben keine Westen an ja die sind nur
mit so einer gelben Jacke erkennbar als
Kommunikation die werden eingepflanzt
mit Stein also worüber reden wir jetzt
hier eigentlich und dann muss man schon
auch sagen wo er hat und das meine ich
natürlich soll man allen Menschen eine
Stimme geben ja aber so eine
Pressekonferenz wäre doch schön gewesen
wenn sie auch jemand von der Polizei
eingeladen hätte und wenn es die
Polizeipräsidentin gewesen wäre dass der
Kollege nichts sagt ist doch klar hallo
der hat ein Recht Verfahren fahren
Polizeipräsidentin von Berlin wer will
in diesen Zeiten eigentlich Polizist
oder Polizisten werden würden sie sich
das antun hat
also mein Berufswunsch war seit ich zehn
Jahre alt bin
Menschenrechtsanwältin zu werden und
jetzt habe ich etwas ähnliches gemacht
deswegen wäre das mein Berufswunsch
nicht gewesen nein das machen nach
Neukölln einem Freitagabend Samstagabend
mit einem Streifenwagen reinzufahren und
dort für Ordnung sorgen müssen
wie gesagt also Polizei ist nicht mein
Berufswunsch das müssen Sie mir jetzt
verzeihen dass ich das nicht machen
möchte das liegt aber nicht daran dass
Neukölln besonders schlimmer Ort ist
denn wenn sie mal die ich möchte eine
Sache dazu sagen heute ist ein
Aktionstag gegen Gewalt der Sonnenallee
und das machen die migrantisierten
Gastronomen die sagen wir wollten sogar
dass dieser kostenlos Essen das war dann
rechtlich nicht möglich also die
Menschen die dort leben die all die
Menschen mit Migration
gewisse Zweifel ob es Neukölln ganz weit
nach vorne bringen würde aber noch
einmal bleiben bei der Frage also
entschuldigung ich finde das Wort toll
ich finde das anders
wo ist denn was ist denn man Neukölln so
problematisch ist ein vielfältiger
Bezirk es gibt überall Probleme aber
bestimmt nicht nur in Neukölln wenn
jetzt die ganze Republik falsch ja
gesprochen es gibt ganz viele Orte
Probleme ich wollte von ihnen ja nur
wissen ob sie sich das antun würden und
zur Polizei gehen würden sie haben dann
den Abzweig genommen dass sie sowieso
schon immer eine Berufswunsch hätten die
wäre das mit ihren Kindern wenn die den
Berufswunsch äußern wenn sie sagen macht
es oder wenn Sie starten also ich finde
dass meine Kinder eine selbstbestimmte
Entscheidung treffen und wenn sie das
möchten ich würde ihnen nicht abraten
weil Neukölln ein besonders gefährliches
Pflaster ist darauf wollen sie hinaus
dass sich ja nicht sondern ich würde
sagen mit welchen Risiken und
Konsequenzen dieser Beruf sowie auch
andere Berufe einhergehen also auch
Politikerin sein das nicht ohne Risiko
wir kriegen auch mordnachrichten wegen
alle möglichen Sachen es gibt viele
Berufsrisiken Polizei hat auch viele
Berufsrisiken das würde ich natürlich
offen auf den Tisch liegen aber nicht
wegen Neukölln wenn er sagen würde ich
will explizit nach Neukölln da hätte ich
jetzt keine Einwände ehrlich gesagt ob
er in Grunewald oder noch neu Köln
möchte ach so
Offenbach und so und aber ich hätte eine
schöne Projektidee weil ich weiß nicht
ob das richtig möglich deswegen wenn man
das hinkriegen könnte die Polizei dass
sie einfach mal in den jungen Mann oder
eine junge Frau wir haben das Thema
duale Ausbildung einfach mal mitnimmt
und die selber erfahren was genau in
diesem Beruf ist und was es bedeutet die
transportieren weiter
weil es ist wieder zu tolles Thema ich
mache das mit den Leuten reden und nicht
über die Leute weil die haben ja
überhaupt keine Vorstellung da müssen
wir verdammt viele Jungs und Mädels aus
verschiedenen Stadtbezirken zur Polizei
bringen aber wer vielleicht ein ganz
winziger Ansatz aus dieser Runde nach
vorne noch einmal Herr tschar der sich
hochgeboxt hat im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes wir haben hier viel über Respekt
gesprochen es gab eine Zeitlang ein
bisschen Verwirrung um ihren deutschen
Pass weil sie immer wieder gesagt haben
na mensch das ist doch auch Schuld ich
will nicht immer nur geduldet sein ich
will richtig ankommen bei euch haben Sie
eigentlich mittlerweile im deutschen
Pass
ich habe mittlerweile einen deutschen
Pass nach 34 Jahren
Integrationsarbeit hat
Integrationsarbeit ich habe mich ich
habe meine ganzen sportgitarre immer für
Deutschland alle Erfolge geholt und den
Klitschko 2012 für Deutschland geboxt da
haben sie mich alle gefeiert 2 14
für Deutschland aber als ich dann 2 17
Weltmeister geworden bin
geschlagen habe ist es auf einmal machen
ihr verlangt von uns Integration wir
geben unser Bestes dass wir uns als
deutsche fühlen Deutschland kämpfen mit
mit Stolz habe ich deutscher Patriot und
dann wird man dann am Ende der Traum
weggenommen wo man dieses Traum erfüllt
Deutschland hat ein deutschen
schwergesetz Weltmeister
Fußball Nationalmannschaft spielt stehen
sie auf und singen die Nationalhymne mit
natürlich warum denn nicht ich feiere
meinen ich feiere mein Land aber auch
hier auf eine Sache wegen Integration
beispielsweise wir wünschen uns
hier bei sich was in Deutschland sich
hier integrieren nach Katar und halten
uns die Hand zum Mund und integrieren
uns nicht wegen einer Fahne also wir
haben dann auch nicht das Recht
immer zu zeigen mit dem Finger wir
müssen uns auch integrieren
den Spanier bin mit meinem deutschen
Freunde nach Mallorca
wir werden gehasst wir Deutschen wir
werden in Mallorca gehasst weil wir uns
auch nicht anständig benehmen weil wir
trinken und alle grundüberweisen man
kann ja ich sage immer so man kann das
nicht immer sofort verallgemeinern wenn
immer so eine kleine Portion von
Nationen sich daneben genommen und alles
in einen Topf schmeißt das ist nicht
schön letzte Frage
in der Vergangenheit auch das geäußert
haben wir uns dann heute jetzt sie mit
deutschen Pass wäre es heute ihr
Präsident ist das immer noch Erdogan
oder schauen Sie stolz auf unser
Bundespräsidenten aber das kann und
unseren Kanzler
und ein Intro hat das Verlangen also ich
fliege nach Berlin mit meinen eigenen
Kosten in Berlin gab es einen Streit
zwischen Araber und die fliege ich rüber
und Frieden das ist nicht so das ist
klar was damals
beantworten bitte das das können was da
alles im Hintergrund damals gelaufen ist
wir müssen diese selbst beenden und
grüßen Grüße wir sind am Ende der
Sendung ja man darf das einfach nicht so
verschieben ich habe was Gutes
die Polizei damals anderer Meinung hier
in Berlin wir beenden einmal ganz kurz
diese Runde weil wir schlichtweg am Ende
dieser Runde sind und ich danke für den
Streit
erlaubt Frau Harald herzlichen Dank sie
müssen zurück in den Wahlkampf danke
Ihnen der Malik fürs kommen aus
Offenbach danke frei für diese ja
streitbare Sendung wir sind nächste
Woche Montag zurück danke Ihnen gute
Zeit
[Musik]